multiple credit cards high balances high
interest rates high stress levels you've
been making payments over a long period
of time but it doesn't seem to have put
a dent in your debt
perhaps you're even considering the
dreaded b word but before you go that
far you may be considering something
called debt consolidation
what is debt consolidation it's simply
taking two or more accounts and
combining them into one and that's where
you'd make your payments well that
sounds good simplifying makes things
easier right
not always consolidating your debt may
mean less paperwork but that doesn't
mean it's the best path out of the woods
there are several different ways to
combine your balances and you should
understand the good and bad of each
before you decide what's right for you
[Music]
one way to consolidate debt is to simply
transfer the balance from one credit
card to another credit card companies
are often happy to do this since it
means you'll get in deeper with them
many will offer a variety of promotions
zero percent apr over the course of
anywhere between 12 to 18 months some
will offer an extended promotion date
but at a slightly higher interest rate
transfer fees are common so be sure to
factor that in this sounds like a pretty
simple way to get some immediate relief
but beware of the fine print most of
these deals involve deferred interest
which means that you're still accruing
interest on your balance during the
whole promotional period when the
promotion expires you are charged all of
that accumulated interest despite the
number of payments you've made yikes
another way to consolidate debt is
through a personal loan you get a loan
from a bank use it to pay off all your
credit cards and then make payments to
the bank sounds simple again there are
some hitches first of all your credit
has to be in a favorable condition to
actually get approved if you've been
struggling to make payments on multiple
cards which you probably are if you're
considering consolidation then it'll be
pretty hard to get a loan and even if
you do the terms probably won't be great
this route only makes sense if you can
get a lower apr on the loan than you
have on the cards
also this method can be very risky for
someone who has trouble restraining
their urge to spend suddenly having
several wide open credit cards may be
too much temptation there are many cases
where consumers have taken out a loan to
pay off all their credit card debt just
to turn around and run the cards right
back up the third option is to seek the
help of a company that specializes in
debt settlement it may sound attractive
to let someone else handle all the messy
details but you should definitely know
how it works
first they ask you to stop paying all
your debts and instead start making
payments into a special savings account
once there's enough there they take that
money and negotiate a payoff with each
of your creditors typically much lower
than the full amount you owe them so
what are the downsides
first their fee which can be as high as
25
of your total debt second since you're
effectively defaulting on your loans
your credit score will get hammered and
third they may not even be successful if
they can't reach an agreement with one
or more of your creditors you'll still
be on the hook for the full amount with
all the fees and damage to your credit
maybe none of these sound like great
options to you well there's good news
many people actually have greater
success by not consolidating their debt
it may sound nice to simplify your
payments but the psychological effect of
having one giant loan can be very
intimidating at a time when you need
discipline and optimism you feel
discouraged and hopeless
by keeping debts separate and focusing
on one at a time you can get a feeling
of accomplishment and pride with each
closed account which can go a long way
to keeping you motivated it's all about
knowing what works best for your
personality if you decide to keep your
debts separate you can negotiate
directly with your creditors for some
leniency often called hardship programs
these policies were developed to assist
consumers that are struggling with
making on-time payments if qualified the
creditors will lower your monthly
payment and interest rate no defaulted
accounts no wasted money paying a
company to do what you can do yourself
but there are some hurdles you may have
to prove that you are actually facing a
hardship shopaholism doesn't count think
family emergencies job losses pay cuts
or medical illness and you may need
documentation to prove it once in the
program the lender will either close or
freeze your account they may also lower
your credit limit if this results in a
high utilization percentage the
proportion between what you owe and the
total you can borrow you are likely to
see a decrease in your scores
in the end there's no one right way to
handle debt the important thing is that
you know what you're getting into and
that you know yourself your personal
strengths and weaknesses will determine
how well each option would work so you
need to take an honest look at yourself
before making a decision
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
patron
if you want more strategies for dealing
with debt check out our video what's the
fastest way to pay off debt
[Music]